Show More
[Music]
Hello Guys Safed Surya Story And Your
Watching Is Date In Two Years With Learning About
OpenCV And Half Inch Data And
Using Both Positive And Half Inch Data
Meeting Ka Tiddu So In This Video We Talk About
OpenCV  And
what are these two about the data of the class and
after this we will use them to create a side effect. Let me
tell this chapter, whatever I will use here, whatever
project I will create,
I will give the link of it in the description. Okay, so
first of all.  Let's talk about OpenCV
What is OpenCV library in fashion
and how does it work Shoppers Stop and
OpenCV Friends to Open Source Computer
vision is basically a kind of real-time
computer vision, which means to detect real-time
objects and  Relay is used to
fry ladyfinger.
It is being used very widely. At present,
where is it happening? If I had an application for you,
it was developed
by Intel before that and secondly, it is free to
use.  You know the noose, you
can use it in any way, you can make any project, the remaining
accused are under PhD license
office collection that apart from you, you can use
any broken flower, so
Intel had made it free to use.  You can
somehow modify this thing and
use it in anything. If you
come to its application then
you will see Jester tracking for motion tracking for facial recognition.  The
whole video is in which the volume is increased with the hand,
updated to the latest, this is also YouTube Open CB name,
OpenCV is used oil and oil is being used in it
everywhere, you can see that Facebook has
seen on Instagram that to track
People can be tracked in a hotel
or in a group of people, if
we remove them, then after testing it, you do something
specific, who is this, who is this,
Open is also used in that, China test
loop, every big company, OpenCV.
Basically it is a competition, clothes are collected,
user
is using in the country, using is only requested, deans should
always explain to the directors, in rural areas
Twitter is used, before using it,
we use the data of Har Gas and a machine learning algorithm to
detect it.  Also, there is
a way for the common man to decide whether the train
is late, any thing you make, it has to be given
data, otherwise you
can understand as if we are making the previous system,
then this Pawan Singh image has been inserted on my face.
So my Facebook does
n't track your face near it, it's something like this,
send some object, turn off the face setting,
son, you can do it, so how will we
tell it how the page looks, so
in the name of editors, there is a lot of this treatment.  And
inside which there are both images of positive images from the call,
such data is
alone train letter is essentially house that this is the
data acid of the sky which
was developed by various scientists. Okay, now we
can use it for reduction.
All the time thinking about these different
types of pollution, first of all your skin is affected by these different types of pollution,
like if I want to celebrate the side action
then how will we delete the file, what
parameters will I add that if the side effect has happened,
then this is what happens, yes,
India's 100  Let's start towards
how we
can create a custom hotspot of constitution of these two anger and yes,
director two, so I will tell you all the things
how you have to download sewerage above,
however today's date A you have to download the
second thing that a
little  -You will have to be a little familiar with the pattern
in this video because here we are going to do
less than Python and do this add
suicide.
We will start tomorrow morning
with our project, so I will
start with the basic first of all, so you have the requirement.  The
pattern will be that your husband will cement, then you will have the
data department of OpenCV Library in Hathras,
so
I will tell you to download it from here and I am
not using Visual Studio code here,
I will use the digest,
if you want then that  20 broken
hearts in a way otherwise I am here for those who use prizes
and
subscribe till the table you can download the apk file
download
play store
that you fear downloading speed then install it here
if already installed
20 active need for  Speed ​​most difficult
tasks
subscribe to
again gender has been defeated cast get
up then if you play its test match then let's
stop you one way or
after that we will tell you about whatever important project is ours then
we just  If this is a
requirement, then here you will see the front page of
Bajrang Dal. Etawah station is very big, these 10
kidnapped people need this necklace to be white, so
I will download only the I.SC value here,
then click on it, Dr.
One week, something like this, Interpress School.  This
simple dance gives
relief from being busy due to bacterial fever,
so while firing the cannon, you simply
download it.
Now first of all, let us download our
Ola app which is called
Wind Pipe
CMD.
How should we download it at this time,
how can we install it for ourselves? Now let us
subscribe.  Turn
on the person Panchami of Saif Ali Khan,
I am here, the requirement has been shown from this point
that they have already started
education, you will also get the number, your stall,
Lokayukta,
in this, we will open the mathematical police that if you
subscribe all around, then
subscribe and already
subscribe.  You can do
[music] for
some time in it, you can download whatever you want
if for ₹ 5 it is absolutely officer dip
daily any problem you can use
Visual Studio and Atom and you can use any Sabir in it, if you mute the
parmesan in it
then I just chart  Appointed on Open Loop
Subscribe Subscribe My Channel
Before this we will do this
Install it in our system So here
first of all use it So for that commando that then that
Comment comment
hua tha cigarette cigarette means computer vision
library so command  Those commands can be
seen from here, so open CVD, the
complete document is this, you can see
G Hall Dhapku
properties, how to use it,
okay, so many properties, Sphinx and
all this, the whole command line, how
and  You can turn off the mode so here we
only need the reports so I am this
simple C to
Jai Ho Om ki
MLA Ravana Dahan we need
subscribe subscribe
whole subscribe so from that
subscribe this
subscribe
project do
n't forget to subscribe subscribe
subscribe school
who  See Into Thoughtless Slipper First on the to-do list
Non-returnable
appointment If he
is a Bank of India Doing is one He
takes love He makes a ruler
Great two [
Music]
Convert Color 10
Subscribe
button
So use
our  Which
can see Meghnad and we are
subscribe
system which
cannot understand in the system so we have it in this way then for that
commando cigarette literally
word cb2 convert
color indicates a
that daily employment using shift our if
infection occurs  Lenskart retention
happens, after that you have to make that cream here, all
around this table, so
this is some value for that, what we are you who add
extra oil means like this
rectangle in which I tell you that this
youth is a victim to make a little  You can make sa with
some of its
command quality, you can like and comment from above, if you
like this video then
enter this code
that dengue dear
yes yes no sugar to I am mourning and
newly appointed above will do a love made house show.
Friend and bite, what are we doing,
as you can see, now
if you go to the chief project, then they are absolutely there, so keep
applying here that the
idli batter,
click the subscribe button,
subscribe
that K Prelims and Destroy All.  World
Whose meaning will close this application except the
death of which this open loop of
this our front door
tied whole can be
completed on Thursday
and you subscribe subscribe so
this is that the
Nakshatra order lesson
was the core
yesterday morning a little on this lamp  C Ardhamagadhi
because my face recording was
completely different, its code could not run
because the camera was in use and was not
able to reverse Dainik
Hussain Tough activation is not there Remedy otherwise
discharge Guddu
this thing Singh Court no
that this house from China border
Upright rectangle form Kunal Roy is
in chief This is a tourist in my
sleep We have made a
complete high detection tool in a very small court using OpenCV and harmful only.
Big companies
of big companies use this thing on a large level.
Neither do they sleep in a different algorithm, you
can use this tool in any way, you can do
face detection
from your schedule and from it you
can make an attendance system and they can become satvik.
I will bring more such projects for you
now on this channel.  K Coordinator
Express And Did To
Friends Please Subscribe Next
9 News Channel And
Share This Video With Your Friends And No
Problem If You Have Any Wire You Can Ask
In The Comment Box Thank
Us